im deutschen bundestag sitzen viel zu
viele abgeordnete wir reden hier vom
größten bundestag aller zeiten quasi vom
gröbers könnte man sagen es ist nicht
übertrieben gesetzliche norm größe für
die bude liegt bei 598 abgeordneten
aktuell sind wir bei 709 wenn wir das
wahlrecht so lassen werden es schon
nächstes jahr über 800 kostenpunkt jetzt
schon über eine milliarde euro pro jahr
gestern wurde das im bundestag
debattiert und wie sehr das ganze
unseren politikern selber auf den nägeln
brennt sieht man hier an den brechend
vollen rängen während der wichtigen
debatte was helfen könnte wäre ein
neuzuschnitt also eine verringerung der
wahlkreise
das ist bis zur wahl 2021 zeitlich
leider nicht mehr zu schaffen sagen
jetzt die groko parteien was extrem
frech ist weil das problem seit über
sechs jahren bekannt ist die hatten also
zeit und sie mauern weil sie besonders
profitieren vom jetzigen system mit
überragen und ausgleichsmandaten meine
klar ist so eine wahlrechtsreform
kompliziert es sei denn man fragt gernot
hassknecht haltet allem adresse jetzt
rede ich über unser wahlrecht so kinder
das ist unser bundestag zweitgrößtes
parlament der welt mit 709 abgeordneten
voller als eintopf in der happy hour
aber keine angst unser
bundestagspräsident der herr schäuble
hat versprochen das problem wird bis
ende januar gelöst hat mal heute ist der
ich habe zwar in hessen abitur gemacht
aber ich meine das ist ende januar hat
das denn geklappt mit der lösung
mai wie schade und wie überhaupt nicht
überraschend
abgeordnete die sich ihre eigenen
mandate weg kürzen sind extrem selten
oder poetische ausgedrückt wenn man den
sumpf austrocknen will darf man nicht
die frösche fragen absolut und die
schlimmsten frösche beziehungsweise
blockierer sind wie immer diesel
tierschänder auf bayern
diese ist nun vorschläge von denen sie
selber profitiert und die spd ist
natürlich noch peinlicher und schreien
sagt gar nichts vor
zu lange schon verfestigt sich ein
verdacht die spd drückt sich einfach weg
die spd hat eine position wir
veröffentlichen gehört derzeit nicht
tatsächlich kommt die einzige
vernünftige idee nämlich das
zusammenlegen von wahlkreisen von linken
grünen und fdp wissen sie was das heißt
zum ersten mal in meinem leben muss ich
den furchtbaren satz sagen
ddp
[Applaus]
mein vorschlag wir müssen den bundestag
endlich unattraktiver machen da müssen
handwerker reihen und die spüle immer
enger aneinander schrauben mein ziel in
sachen beinfreiheit kann ich in einem
wort zusammenfassen
weil er
und natürlich müssen auch bestimmte
abgeordnete nicht raus ich will da jetzt
keine konkreten namen nennen steht mir
auch gar nicht zu aber wenn sich sagen
wir mal jemand als minister beim thema
maut über geltendes recht stellt und
ernsthaft sagt ja ich habe andere
rechtsauffassung als der ogh okay also
kein schüler können sich auch nichts
vorzuwerfen
[Musik]
von den menschen im wahlkreis region
passau lehrfach direkt in den bundestag
gewählt damit entziehe ich denen sie
immer das war recht denn sie können
damit offensichtlich nicht umgehen
ein abgeordneter weniger nur noch 708
wir haben geschehen
servus hans de schreibt über die heute
show ihr seid die richtigen links
[ __ ] besonders welke die stradivari
unter den arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal